let's talk about bunions how to prevent
them and how to get rid of them now the
technical name for a bunion is hallux
valgus it becomes a problem in the big
toe where the toe starts to malform
in three different directions it tends
to bend towards the other toes rotate
and then elevate now the big problem
with this is that it can become inflamed
tender and it really affects your gait
your ability to walk your ability to
exercise
and so you're constantly shifting your
weight on other parts of your foot and
ankle and then this throws off the
symmetry of your muscles and now
you might end up with knee pain or hip
pain
because of the compensation so what are
the causes of this problem well there's
three main causes one is that your shoes
that you wear
are not uh fitting your feet correctly
maybe the toe is too pointed maybe the
shoe is too narrow and this is causing
your big toe to go inward unfortunately
these fashion shoes today are not
designed to keep your toes nice and open
and straight so the first thing you need
to look at is your shoes um
the best thing to do when you're buying
a shoe is to take the bottom of the shoe
and then match your foot to see if
there's space enough for your toes and
if there isn't you're going to have to
find some shoes that actually can really
give your toes some space now that's not
necessarily going to correct
this problem but it can definitely
prevent the problem
now number two um having flat feet like
myself can create a problem with big toe
because there's no arch you're
constantly shifting the weight forward
to the toes especially the big toe and
then that can affect the dynamics of how
you step and then the foot flares out
and now we have a lot of pressure on
that toe
and so now the toe starts going outward
this way and number three
just simply having ankle mobility issues
that could come from an old injury to uh
your ankle or your foot which then it
caused compensation
or it can be from having an aroma on
your foot or a heel spur or any number
of reasons including over training
maybe as a child with some type of
exercise
so
the solution is going to be involving
putting flexibility back into the ankle
which is a lot of the calf muscles that
we're going to be dealing with
so let's just dive right into it okay so
number one
if you have shoes that are not fitting
correctly you need you need to get some
shoes that do fit your toes
and this also includes getting socks
that are not too tight around the toes
they have socks now that
individually fit your toes and that
might be a really good type of sock that
you should get so this way you keep that
separation
okay number two
there is something called silicone toe
spreaders okay so this is just a simple
device that you can put these uh little
spacers between your toes to keep the
separation and you would wear these a
couple hours in the evening to help
start to spread the toes
and number three the exercises which is
probably going to be the most important
thing to focus on now the first exercise
you want to do is focusing on rotation
of the foot you're going to be making
circles of the foot there's a really
good exercise that you can do where
you're sitting in a chair and you're
bringing your knee up with your arms
okay so you're isolating the lower leg
and then you're going to try to draw a
complete circle with your toes clockwise
okay and you're just going to go slowly
to focus on the form
to make sure you get that complete
circle and you're going to notice that
it's it's actually difficult to do at
first because there are certain muscles
that are too tight in other muscles that
are to atrophied or loose but doing this
circular exercise will start to
put in symmetry into that ankle so you
simply start with like 10 rotations
clockwise with your right foot okay and
then do 10 counterclockwise with your
right foot then you would switch to the
left foot and do 10 clockwise and 10
counter-clockwise focusing on doing this
slow
and
doing a complete circle without
involving uh using the leg so you wanna
really isolate that ankle so you're not
rotating the entire lower leg so that
would be one exercise to start with and
do this each day the second exercise i'm
going to recommend would be just
standing on a tennis ball for
two minutes now you're gonna have to
work up to this but you make sure the
tennis ball is right in the mid part of
the arch and you do one foot at a time
and you're standing and you're putting
all this pressure on the arch and this
is really important for people that have
flat feet this will start to take
pressure off these muscles that are
really too tight and give you a lot of
relief so what we're trying to do with
these exercises
is put symmetry
uh back into the ankle joint and muscles
that are related to that so when you're
walking you're not favoring certain
muscles
and then this will allow the toe to come
back now realize that the what's holding
this thing in a certain position is the
muscles so what you're doing is you're
correcting the muscles the ligaments and
the tendons so when you're standing in a
tennis ball you know you might only be
able to do it for 10 seconds so you're
going to gradually start working up to
being able to do it for two minutes each
foot once a day all right the next
exercise would be toe raises okay
and
you want to start sitting in a chair and
you're simply going to raise your toes
up
both left and right at the same time so
and this is going to start to strengthen
a muscle called the anterior tibialis
which are the muscles on the front part
of the leg the shin muscles
and you want to work up to just doing
these 30 times okay 30 times
if you start to cramp obviously stop and
do what you can but we're trying to
strengthen on a nice slow uh gradient
level the front part of the muscles in
the lower leg okay so you're going to be
sitting in a chair and raising up your
toes these are called toe raises and i
recommend working up to like 20 of these
okay so you might be able to start with
10 and then go 20 and then 30 over time
and then once you get good with that you
can graduate to doing this standing
you're going to be positioning yourself
on a wall so you're at maybe a certain
degree like maybe you're doing 30
degrees on a wall and you're going to be
lifting up your toes that way
and i put a link down below of a really
good video just to kind of give you more
information about that so if we're going
to be working on the muscles on the
front part of the leg now we need to
work also on the back part of the legs
so this would be calf raises okay stand
straight then push to the balls of your
feet and raise your heels until you are
standing on your toes to start on a
chair
back and forth
working your way up to 30 repetitions
and then when you get good with this
then you would start doing it um just
standing up okay
and you might want to hold the chair or
the wall as you do these calf raises
you want to work up to 30.
now what you're going to find is the
muscles
and the calf are going to be a lot
stronger than the ones on the front part
of your shin
and this is why it's going to be a lot
easier to do
the calf razors than the toe raises
but i want you to do them both
and then what you're going to find is
you're going to be basically
strengthening the weak length which is
the front part of your leg the anterior
tibialis and that's going to give you a
lot of relief on the big toe and the
last exercise would be where you're
going to be
inverting the ankles okay
as well as everting the ankles so you're
going to rock them back and forth while
you're sitting in a chair okay you're
going to work up to 30 times
then when you get better with that you
can do this standing
so these exercises
cover all the dynamics of the motion in
your ankle and over time it's going to
really put symmetry back into both feet
now let's say for example you just have
more inflammation in one big toe okay
not both of them if you want to get some
instant relief on that a very simple
thing to do would be to massage the
opposite toe exactly where it's hurting
on the right side or the left side you
work on the exact opposite side and as
you press into the opposite
big toe joint okay on the mirror image
side you're going to find it's very very
tender
but it's going to give you a tremendous
amount of relief
on the side that's actually hurting now
of course you wouldn't want to do this
if it's on both sides bilateral you
would only want to do that procedure if
it's on one side however if you do have
it on both sides what you can do
is
start massaging with lotion
on the
inside
space between the big toe and the second
toe
right where you have this little
web between the two toes go down a
little bit further towards the arch and
you're going to find some areas that are
very very tender in between the first
toe and the second toe i would do that
type of massage on both feet it will
give you a tremendous amount of relief
as you're correcting these bunions
all right so now that you have the basic
information the best video for you to
watch next is my one on flat feet check
it out i put it up right here